i i presume you have lots of like you
know maybe is there fan fictions about
you
already i assume so right oh for sure
but i i actually not really one for
reading fanfiction so i actually
good i like that i don't do that either
why not
we've already discussed this joe it's
boring as [ __ ] i don't care for it
all right that's all i know because it's
reading
yes because
because he doesn't like turning book
book words into brain words
yeah true all right whatever
yeah because i'm wondering like do
viewers also like assume
like your relationship with other hollow
life members or anything like that oh
for sure for sure yeah
people yeah it happens is most of it
false
or i mean or do you like kind of play to
that as well
i mean it depends i feel like um i feel
like a lot of people
see my relationships with some of some
of the other members and yeah they draw
their own conclusions and
and i'm friends with all of them i want
to make that very clear
but um there's also a certain there's a
certain point that i want to
uh leave up to you right right to your
imagination
all right have fun that's the most
important part of all of this right
in this business have fun all the fanfic
writers are right all right
dude do it
do it you please okay listen
but um did you just ask people to write
mandarin
what no i didn't know
no trash tastes fanfics no i won't read
it
so do you get to hang out with any other
of the members like off stream as well
yeah
kiara yeah we hang out sometimes for
sure yeah
yeah you guys are kind of like all over
the place right yeah yeah definitely but
occasionally i'm
let's just say kiara lives in a place
that is accessible to me from the
underworld so it's easy to hang right
we went to dinner the other day and it
was fun yeah do you guys like ever talk
about like
the youtuber side of things together or
is it just like completely just
no youtuber talk allowed when we talk a
bit about business and
i mean i feel like there's always
something going on right
in the v tuber scenes there's always
plenty to talk about on that end but of
course
you know we also just talk about what's
what's going on for both of us as well
like a funny mental image of like two
virtual youtubers in the corner at
denny's just [ __ ] yeah
i don't know why let's discuss this
let's discuss business
right right
so you're a 2d anime girl i'm a 2d anime
girl too
hey we should collab
oh my god is there anyone on the
japanese side of things that you would
like to meet in the future
oh for sure i mean it's just the yeah
you know there's
there's this the thing about me that
i've said before is that
i am bad at approaching right i'm bad at
making the first move
because i never want to impose you see
i'm very much in my own lane
and kind of doing doing my own stuff
right and i want to get in anybody's way
um i also i'm always concerned about
does this person really actually like me
and and if they if they don't and i
contact them well then i have to deal
with with that whole weird situation and
then realizing they don't like me and
it's just better that i don't know
you know i just rather not know that you
[ __ ] hate me like a true youtuber
dio's like oh you're approaching me and
he's like no no i'm not
okay do you want me to listen
so i'm like which which uh which whole
life
japan members have you have you met any
of them no
no i haven't they're all rather
mysterious to me still right right
yeah maybe maybe some someday in the
future it just depends on the
collaboration situation and i know
enough japanese to be able to
communicate
yeah um but there will definitely be
bumps and they may be hilarious and they
may be sad
i'm just not sure yet i'm still testing
the waters right because because
because from what i've seen from like
different clips and vods from the
japanese
whole life members is that almost all of
them are like really really interested
in the en side of things yeah i was
wondering i was wondering how much like
cultural cross-pollination there is like
what [ __ ] oh god that was a word
that was a power word right there
cultural cross-pollination
that's probably not even a word right
what i want to know is do you like
english v
what's so funny about it
that was the most business set of words
i'd ever heard in my life
what was i saying oh yes do you get like
a lot of japanese fans where
english clips are like translated to
japanese and everything like that oh
yeah sometimes i'll finish streaming and
three hours later i'll see a clip pop-up
of the stream that i just did with
japanese subtitles over it and i'm like
oh jesus christ that is so
[ __ ] deadly obviously yeah yeah yeah
pretty crazy but
hey i'm very thankful that crosstalk
yeah that's a strong cultural
cross-pollination right there
yeah sorry sorry guys because i i
feel like the real unsung heroes of the
youtube worlds are like the translators
oh yeah for sure
i'd like i don't know how many hours
they put into translating but i i
remember
like if it wasn't for like the
translators i don't think hollow life
would be able to grow as much as it has
all of them like do it for free yeah
like they're not hired to do this [ __ ]
they're just like i just seem
this person so hard that i want the rest
of like my
like you know my language speaking
community to know about them right
yeah that's definitely definitely true i
mean i used to be the same way in like
the music community like the japanese
music community i would translate songs
just because i wanted
other other people in my fringe
community yeah yeah yeah
it's like i knew like that one super
obscure japanese game
never got a release in the west it's
like someone translates the whole thing
and it's like a visual novel
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all the fan
translated visual novels i'm like
there is like 900 pages of dialogue that
you just translated for free yeah
yeah but you love it so much you want
it's crazy to share it with others right
you want them to feel that same
happiness i think that's really cool
shout out to the translators you guys
are the real thank you for the cultural
cross yeah yeah that word whatever it is
we're never going to get over